Exploring Mpumalanga in South Africa
is a photographer's dream.
You sense the vastness of the place.
It's probably one of the most
beautiful landscapes I've ever seen.
In a single day, you can go from rugged
mountains to these vast plains.
You add this dimension of big game
and it makes it a totally unique experience.
This landscape is really meant to be
explored and experienced,
and doing things like this
really gives me a sense of the place.
There's something unique about watching
the sunset over a South African landscape.
It gives this incredible light
that you don't see anywhere else.
It's truly a spectacular experience.